have you seen any of the movie yet I've
seen some pieces of it yeah how our fans
are gonna react minds will be blown I
don't think I I think I think people
will have to go see it twice to fully
grasp what we actually did up there like
we did some pretty crazy stuff this is
your captain speaking
today's exercise is dogfighting two
versus one
hey you gotta be kid
[Music]
[Music]
well Top Gun maverick
yeah spoke to hit theaters in the summer
June but now some push back to Christmas
how are you feeling about that I feel
good I mean you know I think we're
definitely you know not I don't to say
not happy I think we're definitely sad
to not be able to entertain fans this
summer and bring people out to the
theaters and give them an amazing summer
movie and amazing experience but I think
we're also really really happy that like
we'll be able to bring people together
we still have something to look forward
to and we're still gonna bring people
together this time Christmas which
personally makes me more happy because
my birthday is December 27th yeah so
makes me happy but I think you know
we're still gonna have a big fun
entertaining movie that people can go to
and literally Wow and be you know in awe
of all that we got to do in those f-18s
up there so super excited about
Christmas I think it's one of the best
gifts that paramount could give the
world yeah okay so you mentioned the 18s
those are the planes right yeah yeah
okay so did you actually fly a plane
because I know Tom Cruise he's a
stickler for doing his own stunts so did
you
so Tom actually created our entire
training program we all did about 40 to
45 hours of flight training before we
got into f-18s and then once we got in
the f-18s there was always someone in
but there's always a Top Gun instructor
in the plane with us obviously looking
out for us but yeah we got to experience
you know how was that I mean if I saw I
saw the trailer and then I saw a video
you posted on your Instagram some people
have different reactions they pass out
what was your experience like I mean my
experience was amazing I haven't I had
an amazing time I loved every minute of
it I think you get you know your first
flight you get so like amped up with
energy and then like you sit on the
tarmac for about 45 minutes before the
plane actually takes off and then you
know you take off and it is
a hundred times better than any roller
coaster you've ever been on or any car
you've ever driven in and like have
loved the fast right it's just this
amazing experience where you know you
get to be in this this amazing machine
this amazing like aircraft or aircraft
that can save lives and you know go with
thousand miles an hour and also like you
know fly across country and light what
feels like minutes you know understand
like it's just so many things go through
your mind at one time and we were so
prepared because of the training course
that Tom gave us that like you got to
really just be up there and be a pilot
to be honest with you you know I think I
think of my cast me Glenn pal
Monica Barbara Danny Ramirez Louis
Pullman miles teller like we all got to
be pilots you know Marvin Davis like we
literally all got to be pilots and when
we're in the planes like that's what our
where our focus was is being a pilot and
the instrumentation and if we're going
left or if we're going right and where
the Sun is it was it was amazing
[Music]